um
I because I didn't reject him because I
wasn't attracted to him I thought he was
very attractive I rejected him because
he he was like too much of a horror
weakness from you and so and like three
and he'd been just pursuing me for like
years at that point so I was like oh and
maybe he actually like likes me you know
what I mean because it's been like three
years okay that's a long time
was it worth it was the whole reputation
was the whole this whole is whole
reputation did he live up to the
reputation of being a [ __ ]
nothing happened like that with like no
I mean it ended for uh different reasons
but but that wasn't why like it didn't
work out but
um
yeah I guess that like like but I
rejected him for a different reason it
wasn't because I wasn't attracted to him
okay that's not like your typical male
friend you know what about like have you
had a female friend that you've known as
a friend and then you've changed men
don't put women in friend zones
yes they do yes they do listen now
listen listen yes they do they just
sleep with them yes exactly yes yes yes
we don't put women into our friends
with a friend now or like a friend or a
woman
so have you had sex to a woman and
you're no longer interested in having a
casual relationship with her but you're
on good terms she's a friend now isn't
she that's different and she's also
casual sex you no longer having casual
sex only stopped for some reason and
you're still you're still amicable
that's a female friend yeah that that
that I know quite a close that kind of
happens that can happen if a guy but the
difference is opposite of women so you
will put a fair kind of friend zone
without [ __ ] him first
foreign
like I want to like you know play
basketball with her like play like you
know whatever or like you know drink
some room there's a one in a blue moon
type thing so what first I first want to
say too is this um you you I think one
of you mentioned because you mentioned
earlier on
um about you might you said you said
maybe someone have you and so it might
you might reach out to them because they
may say things and do things yeah the
difference what what difference is this
as men we're attached to what we see
right we're much up to what they hear
so you can tell sweet last women and
they fall for you even though I know you
might be trying to see him you say the
right words and you and he'll get you
yeah we don't that same thing doesn't
work with us we like what we see women's
fight or floor I do love me a good sweet
talk
yeah
if you get in mind right when we see a
woman yeah we're seeing her in pretty
much two different ways we will give men
most men all men give women attention
right because you like it actually like
giving attention right yeah but the
thing that I want to say all but I think
women get confused they're confused
sexual attention with romantic attention
so that's because you give attention
doesn't mean that we like you just want
to yeah but like it's different to us
want to wife you yeah but how would we
know because let's say how like let's
say you've got Tinder a guy will only
swipe on you if he's attracted to you
and you go to your first date like very
quickly how do you know if this person's
intent without being pushy that's really
difficult to find out because if a guy
okay is only interested you sexually
first off the bat how do you know I'm
gonna say it's talking to you and then
I'll answer your question so I'm gonna
say it first and say to his dating is
stupid they think we're stupid
it's redundant doesn't make any sense
your grandparents and they got married
quickly they had long relationships
dating work well then why aren't you
married
[Music]
I'm doing the last 15 years that's a
difficult positions
to be continued
only foreign
but I stood it yes but it serves no
long-term purpose okay
so when do you say what do you work from
a guy well the question you say is
actually ask yourself is what you're
dating for you are you dating the
purpose why are you dating what what is
your end goal from David so I have to
ask this on a date so if I'm gonna first
why are you dating somebody why are you
going on dates what is what do you want
from dating to meet someone I like it's
for what what for what what's it what's
the laws that end game
husband right so you then have to when
you meet a guy you have to be explicit
and say to say to him I'm dating to be
married okay if he's not there to be
married and he's wasting your [ __ ]
time
but you don't guess you don't assume
you meet him in a bar you meet him
online I am only dating to be married if
you're not on this you waste that's not
let's not waste my time but when you say
like that kind of like scary yeah
because I don't want to be like married
like now like I'm saying like could be
like four to five years like that's the
end game yeah for a relationship long
term well every four to five years if
you don't if not say if you're not
expliciting on what you want as an
outcome every time you meet somebody you
just drifting along
you might be around four or five years
so you wasted a year of someone who was
never interested in getting married to
anyone in the first place yeah so if
you're not expressed about what you
expect as an outcome then how can you
outcomes you want you need to be you say
right this is what I want if you're not
on this plan then there's no point you
joined you know no point you talk to me
because this is what we're at the end of
it yeah but like guys in the audience
don't you think it's a bit like a bit of
a bearing so on the first day if someone
says to you like oh like I want to get
married and someone has to kind of like
gauge if they want to get married
I said to you I am dating to be married
I'm only dating to be married but I
think like I don't want to marry you but
I'm only getting intention to be married
too high I feel like it makes it puts a
lot of pressure no no but you're what
you're doing is filtering the guys who
have no intention of being married
I would say like even even mentioning
like the word married would freak them
out and it would freak me out if a guy
was like yeah like I don't remember what
does Dana guy and he was like oh like he
was talking about like a proposal like
on the first day yeah it really freaked
me out even though I was I had similar
intentions if you know what I mean I was
say like you know what the first thing
you would say like oh like I'm trying to
get in a relationship and then you know
maybe a few days later you can be like
oh like do you ever oh there we go yeah
yeah yeah
um that would be like oh like you know
are you maybe like looking to get
married but you wouldn't say it on the
first date yeah that's not really a
first date discussion yeah I'm gonna
tell you both you're very wrong and
you're very floating if that's what you
were you're not gonna get away with her
life you know go for life just drifting
I think men also have autonomy like
what's going on in the relationship and
I feel like the man just like okay
because the woman hasn't said it
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table I'm like a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so I feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hands is probably not fair no
you're missing something I'm not saying
to you you want to marry him I'm not
since you're going to propose him